[Music]
i got hired on a monday 1987. i i i was
a failed athlete
i'd like i i
had always planned on playing in the nfl
yep um and then i never had a plan b i
never planned for anything other than
that because that's what i was gonna do
well you know it turns out like dude you
ain't good enough to play in the nfl
right so you like so now you're left
like a lot of young people now what
right so
at the time
this is mid 80s
miami vice was popular and as an
audience we had never seen a cop show
like that right we had seen all the
procedurals detectives responding
reactively to crime scenes doing
interviews patrolmen right and then all
of a sudden sonny crockett shows up on
the scene and
got the hugo boss on he's riding a lambo
around south beach
right and he's he's going into these
mansions and he's meeting with these
glamorous kingpins and there's a ton of
cocaine out on some barge in the harbor
and he's got these like stripper models
bringing them mojitos
right and i'm like
man i like that seems pretty cool yeah
right
so
the reality of it is
what i found the reality is that
that lamborghini it was like a beat down
monte carlo sure right and the hugo boss
suit was like cut off camos and a
wife-beater t-shirt and flip-flops
the the kingpin that that sonny crockett
was dealing with was some like broke
dick dude who didn't have two nickels to
rub together that was sitting at the end
of the bar with his plumber's crack
hanging out right the ton of cocaine
it was an eight ball that was so step
down with baby laxative you'd [ __ ]
before you'd get high off of it right
and then the the the stripper models
that like you see on tv that are like
running with these cats they're like
straight skanks with like three teeth in
their head and tits like sweat socks
with rocks in the toes
and so when i when i experienced it
and it was so much different than what
hollywood had sold me on sure sure i
[ __ ] loved it every day man every day
i loved it it wasn't glamorous
undercover work is a nasty dirty bloody
vomit covered scab of a life and when i
realized that i still
loved it yeah yeah yeah and what was it
that you loved
i loved the challenge of the competition
of it i loved how dirty it was
i didn't have to be the guy with the
gold chains and the rolex and all the
and all the you know driving the the
ferrari
like i didn't care i'd show up like on a
bicycle for deals ride ride a bike
because that's that's how
some of those cats roll how early in the
career was that that that that first
event where you got wounded that well so
like i get hired on a monday yeah right
so i actually was out here in los
angeles got sworn in and i told my
supervisors i want to work undercover i
came to work undercover sure so
supervisor digs in his desk and he hands
me a cassette tape and some headphones
and all it said on it was marty
right so i plug it in and i'm listening
what it was
was
the audio recording of a baltimore
city baltimore police department
narcotics officer named marcellus ward
marty ward holy [ __ ] who
marty in december of 1984 was in an
undercover deal with a heroin
dealer and was shot like five or six
times point blank in a drug dealer's
apartment and marty in baltimore in
baltimore and marty dies on tape
marty like marty dies with his boys
trying to rescue him aunt you hear him
die
right so
so the guy shot him left and then you
hear his backup unit come in trying to
save him yeah and it is
dude i'll send you the recording it's
it it's it's it's hard yeah it's hard to
listen to right so
i come out i'm listening to tape my my
boss is like hey man you still want to
work undercover i'm like yeah man this
dude's a freaking hero like i'm not i'm
not gonna die doing it but right so
four days later i get i g i get hired
i want to work undercover they they make
me listen to the mardi tape they're
trying to like hey dude you need to know
what you're getting into right
four days later
i get taken hostage and shot
um
a the bullet went in my back it went in
uh between my uh can you just how did
you get how did you get taken hostage so
actually it's there's there's so many
stories and backstories to everything
right i know i know so
so like i'm brand new and like i've i
haven't been to the academy i don't have
any training um i i i wasn't a street
guy right
so i'm like on the the outer tertiary
like most distant perimeter of this
arrest operation
the suspect shows up
he shows up on a motorcycle gets off his
motorcycle parks in front of his house
starts walking in
boom all the units all the all the
surveillance units start swooping in on
them
to um
to make the arrest sure well he he takes
off he takes off running
and so unlike i'm in so far in the
distance like i'm supposed to just be
staying out of the out of the work right
i see the cat running while i start
running right so
like
i was i wasn't fast enough to play in
the nfl i was slow
but i was freaking out yeah yeah i was
uh usain bolt for in cop land
so i start like i'm passing dudes and
jason we're running through the
neighborhood and he's serpentine and
zigzagging yeah and i and i lose the
dude he vanishes he knows where he's at
i don't know where he's at yeah
a short time later
like we're we're just kind of searching
creeping for the dude and he's here are
you still do you still have your guys
around you or they're like we're all
spread out okay
right so everybody's like you know
there's like no one's really nearby or
close um
and the dude was hiding man and he
popped up and and drew down on me and i
like i had my gun and he was like
[ __ ] i will [ __ ] kill you
where you stand right and i'm like
you know i don't remember seeing this uh
episode of my advice right right right
the dude gets behind me puts the gun to
my head and and he puts his gun to your
head right and he says i'll kill you
where you say has anybody ever said that
to you in your life that had anybody
drawn a gun on you before in your life
no
so now there's a gun at your head what
do you fee what are you feeling man well
like i didn't have uh
like those types of life experiences to
refer back to like okay what do i do now
right but there but there is a sports
element to it there is a like a football
element to it things are breaking bad
there's chaos there's panic man you're
losing the game
you don't help yourself by becoming
hysterical right
you find your you find your zen you find
a sense of calm and you try to like let
your computer run you know let the
champion work i mean have you ever seen
anyone else with that little experience
go to that place
i mean
i i mean i imagine it's like you were
specifically
wired that way both you know from
football
you know the blood that your your mom
and dad put in you you know i mean not
most peop most people get a gun to their
head like that
and i mean they're pissing their pants
right they're not getting tactical you
got
you took a breath and got tactical and
again it's not hero worship nothing like
that i'm just wondering
what is going through your your head i
mean a gun was once put put you know put
to my head once in in russia and and i
knew into i felt like i was this bit
like i i immediately turned into a book
i was literally like you i i'm here for
you i'll do whatever you want i'm just
wondering what went through your because
i i look i know this story i want you to
tell the rest of the story but like how
do you go tactical at that point
um
because i mean you didn't have a ton of
training right now i had no training but
i think it's uh it's it's an inherent
survival instinct like like panic's
gonna get me nowhere panic's gonna get
me shot like right now
um
in in any kind of situation like those
life and death situations if you're
talking if you're communicating you're
alive you're still in the game yep just
keep moving right keep like keep
thinking keep planning okay so what
happens next so
the dude uh
has got the gun to my head and
uh i talked about this old like like i
thought i was coming out of the job to
this lamborghini right like this old
monte carlo right that we used to show
up there he stuffs me in the front see
the monte carlo he gets behind me and
he's got the gun to my head
um and he's like saying like go like get
me out of here right like like he like
he wanted to use me as his vehicle to
escape the situation well now the other
agents are starting to close in right
so i'm thinking like you know what man
this this probably has got a bad ending
but
like i'm not going to drive this dude
away from here with all these other
agents all these other armed agents i'm
not going to drive this dude away from
here and and have him
kick me out and execute me in the ditch
20 miles down the road you knew that
that was what was going on right i was
like if this is going down it's going
down and were you playing the the audio
i mean in your head i mean did you go
back to the to the baltimore undercover
agent yeah yeah absolutely right i'd
only heard that tape a couple days
before right so it was like that that
story was super fresh in my mind yeah
and and and marty's demise and and oh
right
so
i'm sitting there and i'm sitting behind
the wheel and i see a telephone pole
like 30 yards up in front
the first thing i thought is like i'm
going to buckle my seat belt and i'm
going to run us into that telephone pole
as hard as
i can get this car going as fast as i
can get it going
and
that's that's going to at least give me
a chance right
so i'm going to buckle my seat belt and
the keys are in the ignition of the
car
and i'm like okay plan b man i pulled
the keys out and i dropped him to the
floorboard
and he's screaming at me like let's go
let's go let's you know he's he's he's
he's uh he's messed up um and i reached
forward to grab the keys and when i he
tried to ride forward with me and the
gun came off my head the gun actually
moved to my back he's trying to stay
with me and ride me right and he's
holding the gun on my back
and
then
everything breaks bad he fires around
hits me in the back goes through my lung
narrowly misses my heart exits my chest
and then that inspires like literally
uh this lead and glass storm like that
that you could only imagine in a movie
right right it was like it was five or
ten seconds i think like
20 or 25 rounds were fired into the car
right into the into the compartment we
were in
um
so i brought this because i because i
knew that story would come up right
so
that hole right there that's where the
bullet went in my back come on man right
and this hole right here
that hole right there
is where it came out of my came out of
my chest
right so like i said got hired on a
monday like this goes down four days
later on a thursday with the feds
john we get paid every two weeks i
didn't even gotten a paycheck yet
i didn't get it i come from this one
this was on the house man this was like
a test drive like hey man can i try can
i come back tomorrow
right
and there was like i mean i'm laying in
the dirt and
dog crap of this
trailer park
and there's blood coming out of my chest
like you're holding your thumb over the
end of a garden hose just
squirting out and then they dragged the
suspect out of the back of the car
because he i mean they ventilated this
dude
his eyes are rolled back he's already
got the death rattle going
and
so they push me now into the back seat
of this car
and i'm like and i'm i'm in bad shape
myself yeah and so the same car that the
shooting took place in we take off for
the hospital
and so like and my boss was driving who
was like a good experienced like
old-school cop and he's driving and
hauling us and he's looking over his
shoulder into the back seat like hang on
hang he's called everybody bubba hang on
bubba hang on bug stay with me bubba and
then he's driving and driving and
driving and he's like man do you know
your weight do you know the way to the
hospital because we were down
and i'm like i got blood gushing out of
my chest and like glass is all in me
right and i'm like like my ears are
bleeding and i [ __ ]
so but you know what
um
it has a really it has a really happy
ending it has a good ending actually the
the trauma surgeon
that that operated on me is a guy named
dr richard carmona okay um and he was
this young like super hot shot trauma
surgeon right so he patches me up he
saves my life
dr carmona ultimately becomes the
surgeon general of the united states
under president bush wow um and is just
is a is a a remarkable
amazing man amazing life's experiences
wow um so
like like what's the chance that this
all goes down and then i land in the
hands the best of the time yeah trauma
surgeon on the planet yeah right there's
hit that like
there's always a silver lining yeah yeah
yeah and then
and then
the decision i mean just because i i i
gotta asked
was there any doubt i mean was there was
there any like i don't know if this is
for me like what like
i mean you you jump right back in
correct well so i'm in the hospital and
i'm and i'm recovering
and
like the uh the ambulance chaser
attorneys are lining up like it's like
uh like trying to return something at
home depot like hey take a number man
i'm now serving number 17 right right
they were all taking their turn and they
were coming in saying
dude you haven't been trained the the
government the agency has assumed a huge
amount of liability for allowing this to
happen to you how much money do you want
and i'm like like i i mean i grew up in
a blue collar house man my dad was a
carpenter right and my mom
was a house cleaner right
um
they're like you ever seen five million
dollars and i'm like
no yeah how about 10 million dollars you
know what that looks like
i can get you
money that's generational money like
you'll never have to work another day in
your life neither will your kids or
their kids if you're smart with this i
did it right right um
like like your family will be taken care
of forever and all i could think of was
like like get out like there's no
there's no cop who ever
took a badge and a gun thinking that
they were gonna get rich right thinking
that they were gonna you take it for
other reasons right right and and so the
money's the money set like now at 60 i'm
thinking like man you know what
[Music]
snake